cécile untermaier bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin dans
la matinale de rtl france on le disait
vous êtes la rapporteur de la
proposition de loi sur le régime
indemnitaire des membres du conseil
constitutionnel
c'est rare il a été adopté à l'unanimité
des groupes politiques de l'assemblée
nationale oui tout on fait tous les
groupes sur tout l'échiquier politique
on considérait qu'il était effectivement
du rôle du parlement de fixer ces
déterminations montagny laquelle 63 de
la constitution de noeux laquelle
compétences ou au parlement pour le
faire l'ensemble des députés de la
commission des doigts et d'autres
d'ailleurs venu à cette occasion ont
manifesté leur volonté d'une
régularisation et d'une option du
parlement en ce sens qui permet à la
fois de deux natures de fixer comme le
demande la constitution aux
parlementaires mais d'autre part de
d'ajouter de la transparence qui devient
un élément déterminant de la politique
et de la confiance que l'on peut
rétablir ou établir pour renforcer ou
affermir avec les citoyens et puis la
dépendance de l'air de l'art du conseil
constitutionnel parce que vous imaginez
bien que s'ils étaient dans la main d'un
exécutif qui décide de sa rémunération
nous pourrions avoir des doutes sur
l'art et à la dépendance qui doit qui
avoir entre avec les critiques on tourne
beaucoup de loi puisque dans
l'initiative de l'échantillon de toutes
les lois que nous votons et un conseil
constitutionnel qu'il est pas sûr qu est
ce que vous lisez finalement montré du
doigt c'est plus le les montants ou plus
le fait qu'il n'y ait aucune base légale
je pense que d'abord on ne fallait
connaître les montants
je crois que moi ce que j'ai considéré
en fait une petite étude sur l'union
européenne et que les réparations ne
sont pas futé des rémunérations
scandaleuses d'elle correspondant à des
rémunérations tout à fait équivalente
dans le reste de vie des européens
quelquefois
elles sont légèrement inférieurs
quelquefois ils sont elles sont
supérieures donc pour moi le sujet
premier n'était pas là le sujet premier
il était de donner une base légale et
une base constitutionnelle à une
rémunération et lui donner de la
transparence et on s'aperçoit que le
parlement ait finalement l'institution
qui permet par le débat public tel qu'il
s'est opéré hier et par le vote à
garantir fait à cette transparence que
nous devons bien évidemment aux citoyens
qu'ils nous apportent leurs suffrages et
nous font confiance
alors il y a quelques jours c'était
l'augmentation de 2750 euros par an de
la dotation matérielle des députés qui
avaient fait polémique
c'était une augmentation justifiée
d'ailleurs pour faire face aux diverses
activités en période de pandémie est ce
que cela vous a chuchoté également ou
alors vous comprenez que cet ailier
finalement au fonctionnement de la vie
d'un député
écoutez moi à titre personnel je
n'utiliserai pas cette importation
dotation je n'ai pas eu et j'ai jamais
utilisé leurs cartes et bella de
teinture qui nous est alloué
tu pourras pour pour parler d'action
particulière qu'elle vise
j'étais pour ma part assez laid contente
en période de pandémie est en période où
là où la crise est très douloureuse pour
beaucoup d'acteurs économiques et de
particuliers que nous montrions ainsi
notre insuffisance à arriver à pallier
les difficultés financières parce que
les difficultés financières d'eads avant
bien sûr d'un côté avec une majoration
frais mais nous l'avons aussi en
diminution dans d'autres et tout cela
plus équilibrée semble-t-il pour moi
j'étais pas sur le fond je n'étais pas
d'accord sur la forme je n'étais pas
d'accord non plus puisque je n'ai pas
épeler informé et je pense que des
groupes politiques n'ont pas été
informés de cette démarche
donc vous n'utiliserez pas vous
l'enveloppent à titre personnel ce que
vous nous dites en annonçant qu'elle
ment pas alors en tout cas vous le
rappeliez une
une situation sanitaire qui a entraîné
une grave situation économique je vous
propose d'écouter isabelle boyer elle
est déléguée nationale daté dé quart
monde
on a même nommé je pense la période
convient que étant une crise humanitaire
on est en crise humanitaire en france
aujourd'hui
sauf que penser institutionnalisée
l'aide alimentaire c'est une hérésie
c'est une hérésie ça veut dire qu'on
prend acte définitivement qu'en france
et des millions de gens qui vont qui
meurent de faim qui qui sont obligés de
se battre pour pour pour véritablement
nourrir se nourrir ou nourrir sa famille
le fait que l'on passe aujourd'hui à
près de 8 millions de personnes qui font
appel à l'aide alimentaire
c'est quand même l'indicateur majeur de
l'échec de la lutte contre la pauvreté
en france
donc si on peut à la fois améliorer les
actions du côté alimentaire avec des
actions d'accéder à l'alimentation
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire dans ce
domaine mais l'objectif principal c'est
de faire que les gens n'aient plus
besoin d alimentaire on entendait à ce
terme là la france est en vie une crise
humanitaire
selon les propos de la responsable atd
quart monde à ce que vous partagez ce
constat évidemment évidemment que nous
sommes en difficulté majeure est que la
crise se tuer les deux vendeuses qui
nous prenons pas les devants nous avons
d'ailleurs une niche
un de mes collègues socialistes qui va
travailler sur les écarts de regoûter et
dénoncé des cas qui ne font que
s'amplifier donc nous avons bien sûr la
crédibilité a devant nous mais il faut
bien sûr corriger aussi et des cadres
venus et devenir vraiment au soutien des
personnes qui sont dans des difficultés
et ses difficultés elle risque
effectivement de s'accentuer avec
l'embellie corps qui correspondrait à
une crise yannick acquis trésor alors
les républicains eux aussi se montre
mobilisés contre la précarité
on peut défendre la liberté économique
et la solidarité nationale avance-t-il
voyez quelques-unes de leurs
propositions pour permettre aux français
de lille décemment permettre à tous les
français de vivre décemment limiter les
frais bancaires à 25 euros par mois
pendant un an
prix garantis sur un panel de 30
produits d'hygiène féminine et infantile
mieux protéger le patrimoine personnel
mise en place d'un ticket carburant est
ce que ce sont des mesures que vous
pourriez soutenir évidemment
puisqu'elles vont dans le bon sens
l'important c'est de c'est de redonner
du pouvoir d'achat à ceux qui n'en n'ont
pas déjà donc il ya eu une bévue vraies
questions sur ce point je pense
évidemment il faut le faire mais à mon
sens l'action doit être beaucoup plus
massive pour que on est les fois qu'on
travaille dans deux dans une politique
de lutter digne de ce nom
je pense qu'il faut être beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus ambitieux dans dans cette
action nous avons des propositions qui
vont dans ce sens dans la discothèque à
30 8 février
je pense aussi aux étudiants qui sont
dans dans de réelles difficultés qui
sont de temps dans les allemands jets
d'eau pour lesquels on aurait pu agir
beaucoup plus exister
concernant les étudiants très touché par
la crise pour le moment le gouvernement
ne veut pas entendre parler de du rsa
jeunes
il parle de crainte d'assistanat il
préfère élargir la garantie jeunesse 1
qu'est ce que vous en pensez justement
de ce rsa jeunes bah écoutez ce que je
pense c'est que peut-être que la période
actuelle
oblige en tout cas rsa jeune maman t'a
dit voilà je pense qu'il faudrait une
expérimentation sur le rsa jeunes
avaient dans la difficulté que
rencontrent actuellement les étudiants
qui sont quand même les grands sacrifiés
de cette crise qui n'ont pas qu'ils
n'ont pas les cours qu'il souhaiterait
qu'ils n'ont pas les contacts avec les
professeurs qui n'ont pas la vie
collective qu'ils souhaiteraient ils se
retrouvent souvent dans leur famille les
cantiques sont désargentés c'est
extrêmement compliqué donc je pense que
rsa en tout cas expérimental en raison
de la crise aurait tout toute sa
justification
la garantie jeunes nous l'avons mis en
place je pense que c'est un outil
formidable qui vient à un moment où les
familles et où disent intéressés sont
totalement démunis de toute action
moi dans mon travail de député dans ma
circonscription j'ai pu diriger des
familles qu'ils ignoraient que
disposition vers la garantie jeunes et
ça a été un soulagement formidable pour
celle ci dont bien sûr amplifié la
garantie jeunes et pourquoi pas une
expérimentation d'un rsa jeunes je suis
contre fictivement le nabi facile qui
pourrait être accordée à des jeunes est
de décourager du travail mais je pense
que nous sommes pas du tout dans ce
cadre une figure actuellement notre
jeunesse et notre bien le plus précieux
investir dans la jeunesse a toujours été
extrêmement positifs et je pense que
nous le devons pour des raisons
strictement humanitaires et de
reconnaissance de la place dans notre
société
vajna justement qui sera au coeur du
déplacement du président du chef de
l'état aujourd'hui à nantes
il devrait annoncer des mesures
concernant l'égalité des chances et
l'accès aux écoles de service public pad
annonce concernant la suppression de
l'ena elle avait été pourtant proposé
par le chef de l'état après la crise des
gilets jaunes mais plutôt on se
dirigerait vers des places pour des
candidats issus de milieux modestes qui
serait réservé à au sein de l'ena est ce
que c'est une bonne chose
écoutez moi je pense que les bains a
quand même
là c'est pas mon groupe qui passe et moi
à titre personnel dans ma vie
professionnelle comme dans ma vie
politique je combats à la fois la haute
administration et jean reconnaît les
qualités
nous avons besoin de personnes qui sont
issus de l'état par contre sans doute
faut-il revoir les parcours revoir les
plaque dorée qui sont donnés
immédiatement et au contraire les a trop
de l'actuelle est la plus réelle dans un
parcours qui est un parcours que tout
que tout que toute personne doit
connaître sur les lacs et et on vous dit
que ce que je regrette dans les nasses
et le fils de fido mètres de réseau
c'est le phénomène de culture partagée
qui fait que au sein au sein de l'état
nous avons une force de haute
administration qui chante en au
détriment sans doute des personnalités
politiques que sont les ministres et que
sont les parlementaires le thème dont
vous avez bien voulu que le thème que
vous avez vous évoqué en début
d'interview montrent que finalement le
conseil constitutionnel est le député
s'arranger bien de ces dispositifs de
parité et qu'il n'y avait pas le
parlement c'est-à-dire les hélicos le
faire on en ignorait tout cela et
d'éviter ainsi taire l observateur qui
publie qui a travaillé là dessus
donc je crois que tu te cacher les
réseaux notre de la transparence et
faire en sorte que chacun soit en
responsabilité dans telle institution en
jouant en remplissant toute la
compétence qui permet à la france
d'avoir une démocratie qui soit vraiment
une démocratie amélioré alors on arrive
au terme de cet idiot mais peut-être en
quelques mots vous parliez de cette de
voûte volonté de voir se casser les
réseaux on en parle dans ces derniers
jours sciences po entaché notamment par
la sphère du la sphère duhamel a une
l'élite montré du doigt sur les réseaux
avec le hashtag s'ils ont ce sport
qu'est ce que quel est votre regard sur
sur ce que l'on vit ses derniers jours
plus tard garde terrifiant clarifier sûr
sûr sûr sûr cette vie et sur la façon
dont les valises à faire finalement nous
submerge fait des années et des années
plus tard avec qui ont souffert pendant
toutes les années je pense qu'on a un
vrai travail inventant un travail moi
j'ai pas de jets pas de comment dire de
sympathie particulière pour pour du
label bon je pense au contraire j'ai
même songé il est puni par où il a pêché
d'une certaine manière le sujet il n'est
pas là le sujet il est sur les victimes
et sur la nécessité en fait au delà des
dispositifs d'infractions pénales que
nous pouvons mettre en place et inventer
avoir un travail extrêmement claire
éducatrice dès le plus jeune âge sur la
relation qui fait qu'aucun adulte ne
peut se permettre d'avoir une relation
sexuelle avec un enfant aucun adulte
bien évidemment et l'inceste doit être
considéré comme un crime
à part de ces deux de ces violences
sexuelles je pense que nous allons nous
orienter dans cette boîte est tout à
fait nécessaire mais sachant aussi que
c'est pas cela qui va donc totalement
arrêtée un tel comportement
il nous faut l'éducation est peut-être
que ces réseaux là nous aide justement à
apercevoir tout la réalité d'avants deux
très catho que ne voulons pas voir
merci beaucoup cécile untermaier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes député ps de saône et loire
[Musique]